uh-oh here we go so what are you doing
what are you doing with that one
why are you shaking it do we have to add
to it uh-oh what's happening you're
shaking something that can't be good oh
is this the last step
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
well i'm not going to let you do it and
then be called soft so gone this far
right
whoa that's not a dab
is that enough that's enough that's
funny it's got some liquid action yeah
yeah
already
gonna put a couple dabs whoa shall we
cheers cheers
shoes cheers last one her majesty queen
of england to the queen to the queen
okay
oh
cheers my friend
oh that's working hard
oh that's just straight pepper i don't
even taste
like
chicken
i'm going down
the walls are closing in they know how
it goes
yeah yeah
if you're on this show
don't lick your lips what kind of
example are we setting for the children
right right if we don't do this
kids try this at home
don't try that at home kids you look
like you're you're distressed
somewhat
somewhat i'm glad to see it's bothering
you
listen we're both going through it
together we're sharing this experience
and the only way to truly put a bow on
this thing before we send you on your
way just one more cumbersome task before
we roll credits what is the first beat
that materializes within you when you
think about conquering the wings of
death today
it's hard to play harmonica when your
tongue is
twice its normal size who understands
these songs i make now that shawn's
become a dalai lama justin timberlake
and as i see you there
i'm sweating now baby
spicy baby
yeah that last minute was really
unnecessary man
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
fire
i have fire on my face nothing's
happening in my life my my life's on
fire right now when life gives you the
tenth wing with a dab
you take that dab and you finish the
whole damn way
card carrying spiceman spiceman i have
many leather-bound books
[Music]
hot ones truth or dab the game the kick
comes complete with 250 question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table you take turns
being the host being the players and
when you're a player and you get asked a
question you have a choice just like in
the show answer it honestly or suffer
the wrath of the last dab and take a
look at this there's even a mini bottle
of the last dab included i suggest you
have napkins on hand you have to have
some milk on hand and of course be
careful be very careful around the eyes
hot ones truth or dab the play at home
game is available at shop.firstwe
fees.com heatness.com and amazon play at
your own risk wings not included